[Música]
ó alma que fala daqueles muito bem vindo
a mais de 16 mil o estrago de que o
pedido se o pedido feito filha que
alguns truques com o kids pneus e um
ataque muito mesmo a lei por meio
virtual rolando azul branco preto
amarelo eo uso aberto em 2004 foi que
vão só tal como eu disse quando vou
tentar aqui fazer alguns truques com
pedidos pneus e pacificação pró gestão
não mexe eu vou tentar ver que alguns
produtos vão tentar ensinar também para
vocês terem noção da mãe muito de sódio
vão mudar os pneus - o senhor embalagem
diz que 52 minutos e meio diz nunca fica
milão assim imaginem só ficar sem dois
minutos e meio é muito tempo lá meu
vamos tentar bater metas nós continua
até hoje 250 mil likes mesmo vídeo que
vou tentar fazer aqui um espinheiro um
pouco mais arriscado e perigoso com um
choque com um pouco um vídeo no youtube
que é o vai tentar em casa nenhum pedido
também e vão construir o primeiro
chama-se símbolo entre 3 2 1
[Música]
eu sempre vou ver como é que alguns que
não saiu não sei de fazer cinco vezes
seguidas para defender o bayern agora a
cabeça e agora tem passado devido pedido
[Música]
o próximo encontro com o intuíto eu acho
que é só passar uma rodada muito
complicado
[Aplausos]
[Música]
amanhã em sua 5º e um truque chamas
espina difícil no antes era muito
difícil é muito efeito e os donos da
casa conseguem também fazer e só ataque
ronaldo vou ensinar um truque vamos ver
se não consegue fazer
ae
eu juro
[Música]
só aqui está um novo álbum com um
espírito novo nada ocorreu
[Música]
só vou ficar porque os filhos já estavam
estava aquele que a meta dos 250 mil à
equipe que eu faço um pedido opinam
exclusivo com fogo quando adicionado
aqui quanto lá fora agora 250 mil
identifiquem bem
a empresa